What are some best ways to deal with stress?
So that's a good question. We all have stress. Certainly when we get to diagnosis, it's a cause of stress, you know,
dealing with other people in a cause of stress, dealing with work issues could be a cause of stress.
So there's lots of causes of stress. So always when you're dealing with anything, you want to try to
do your best to mitigate the cause. So if the cause of my stress is, you know,
what unhappy relationship, try to work on that relationship. If you cause your stresses too much work at the office,
try to deal with that and talk to your boss or whatever. You know, you try to get to the cause always when you're dealing with anything.
So that's just your health issues. You're trying to deal with causative factors. That's going to be the best way to deal with it.
So let's say you've done all of that, but it's just this inner angst, this inner stress in my body. I just feel fatigued.
You might have symptoms of adrenal burnout or adrenal fatigue. What are some ways to deal with that?
Well, from a nutritional standpoint, diet is really important. So if, you know, you're eating foods that are highly inflammatory,
that's going to make it worse. We tend to crave sweets and salty things when our adrenals are fatigued.
So that is, you know, what is the science of adrenal fatigue is craving salty foods.
That's not the only reason why you would crave salty foods, but it is a sign. So dealing with inflammatory causes in our diet, typically like food sensitivities
and things to calm down the inflammation that could be going in our gut, that could help.
From a nutritional, nutraceutical standpoint, taking adaptogenic herbs that could help balance your hormones. That could help.
If you're interested in doing objective testing with stress, getting the Dutch test done looks at all your hormones, including cortisol curve.
So your tested cortisol levels four times during the day, it should have a nice certain looking curve should be normal.
And you want to measure that so you can see, you know, if there is an issue with your adrenal hormones at all, it can be other hormones that could be causing it too.
So those are the first things I think of. If you think of like what is a supplement that I could do, take to help with stress, anti-inflammatories, like curcumid, as well, you know, things like that.
And then adaptogens are the most common thing that you would use for helping with stress to help balance your hormones.